hey it's hannah LA with bloomberg
pursuits and we're here with the new
Jaguar XF this is the second generation
of the car jag designed as a sports
sedan to compete with things like the
BMW 5 Series than mercedes e-class it's
the latest of the new whips that we can
expect to see from the makers of cars in
the latest James Bond film Spectre it
looks just about as good as
double-oh-seven in a suit to with a
feline arch nose sculpted strong sides
and a firm rear end it also sounds great
the more i drive jaguar cars the more i
loved a particular sound of aggression
in their throat inside it has more
interior space and a sporty or body than
its predecessor and it's seventy-five
percent aluminium skeleton makes it 265
pounds lighter as well it has new
luxurious leather and wood materials
made to casa and comfort jaguar says
nice and under the hood the XF comes
with two variations on its supercharged
v6 engine it also comes with a strong 8
speed automatic transmission that gets
to 60 miles per hour and five seconds
all-wheel drive LED headlights and laser
heads-up display are optional I'd opt in